[Música]
salvo el primer buque cargado con 26.000
toneladas de cereal planearon el barco
razón y partido desde el puerto de
odessa hacia el líbano pero primero hará
una parada en estambul para su
inspección es el primer logro del
acuerdo de exportación que pactaron kiev
y moscú con la mediación de turquía y la
una
crece la duda sobre si la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes de eeuu
nancy pelosi visitará a taiwán en su
gira por asia hoy los tres medios
principales de la isla sostienen que
ella llegaría el martes ni pelosi ni
taipei lo confirman y china advirtió que
esto traería graves consecuencias
analizamos en esta emisión
irán advierte que tiene la capacidad
técnica para producir una bomba atómica
pero que no tiene intención de hacerlo a
la par plantea la posibilidad de
reanudar las conversaciones para revivir
el acuerdo nuclear
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
yo soy maría clara calle gracias por
estar con nosotros iniciamos en ucrania
desde el sur del país en el puerto de
odessa zarpó un buque cargado de granos
ucranianos el primero que logra
abandonar las costas desde que inició la
invasión rusa el barco razón y llevará a
poco más de 26.000 toneladas de cereales
a trípoli en líbano sin embargo la
operación de salida fue delicada pues
ucrania ha minado el mar negro para
evitar una ofensiva de los rusos otros
16 buques están ya cargados en odessa a
la espera de la autorización veamos el
informe
a bordo del ratón y que navega con
bandera de sierra leona más de 26.000
toneladas de maíz ucraniano un miembro
de la tripulación compartió su alegría
por haber zarpado tras meses de estar
atrapado en el puerto bajo la constante
amenaza de bombardeos y
fue una sensación increíble me sentí
como si fuéramos libres después de haber
estado detenidos durante mucho tiempo
el embarque fue posible gracias al
acuerdo alcanzado el mes pasado entre
ucrania y rusia con la intermediación de
turquía y las naciones unidas- el pacto
pretende permitir el paso seguro de los
barcos de cereales y fertilizantes desde
los puertos de odessa el buque llegará
primero a estambul para su inspección
antes de dirigirse a trípoli en líbano
el día del alivio para el mundo tuiteó
el ministro de asuntos exteriores
ucraniano mientras quien celebraba el
acontecimiento como un paso para evitar
el hambre en el mundo
ucrania es un importante productor de
cereales con un 10 por ciento del
mercado mundial de trigo y un 15 por
ciento del
pero la guerra ha impedido que sus
barcos salgan de los puertos lo que ha
provocado un aumento de los precios
mundiales de los alimentos se espera que
más barcos zarpen en los próximos días
según funcionarios presidenciales
ucranianos 17 navíos están atracados en
los puertos del mar negro con casi
600.000 toneladas de carga el desbloqueo
de los puertos también proporcionaría a
ucrania el dinero que tanto necesita ya
que los ataques rusos continúan incluso
en granjas y silos
el secretario general de la onu antonio
guterres celebró la exportación de
granos ucranianos afirmó que es un
alivio para la seguridad alimentaria del
mundo ejemplo medio oriente y áfrica
dependen en gran medida de los cereales
de ucrania y de rusia guterres agregó
que el programa mundial de alimentos de
la onu planea comprar unas 30.000
toneladas métricas iniciales de trigo
para repartir fuera del país en
conflicto
lo que hemos presenciado hoy en odessa
es un importante punto de partida debe
ser el primero de muchos barcos
comerciales que traerán alivio y
estabilidad a los mercados mundiales de
alimentos la gran iniciativa del mar
negro permite volúmenes significativos
de exportaciones desde tres puertos
ucranianos o de esa cherno more tsk y
youzhny junto con la facilitación
acordada del acceso sin obstáculos de
los productos alimenticios y
fertilizantes rusos a los mercados
mundiales traerá alivio y estabilidad a
los mercados mundiales de alimentos y
abordarán la crisis alimentaria mundial
asegurando que los fertilizantes para
cereales y otros artículos relacionados
con los alimentos estén disponibles a
precios razonables
para los países en desarrollo es un
imperativo humanitario y seguir
ministerios impartidos los tres
periódicos más grandes de taiwán afirman
que la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de eeuu nancy pelosi
visitaría la isla en su gira por asia y
que llegaría el martes en la noche ni
pelosi ni taiwán han confirmado la
noticia y por su parte de china advirtió
que el viaje traería graves
consecuencias y es que pelosi sería la
primera funcionaria de alto nivel de
eeuu en visitar el territorio autónomo
desde 1997 un territorio que china
considera como propio para analizar las
consecuencias nos acompaña carlos
veríssimo analista en política exterior
señor veríssimo gracias por estar de
nuevo con nosotros aquí en france 24
comencemos hablando de por qué le
molesta china que pelosi visite a taiwán
la maría clara buenas tardes china la
verdad es que se molesta por una visita
que está enmarcada no en ir directamente
a taiwán sino en una visita en todo
hacia donde me los iba a visitar una
gran cantidad de aliados a eeuu ya
muchas democracias y sistemas que son
mucho más republicanos si china en
general en esta última etapa lo que ha
hecho es que ha exacerbado sus anuncios
pero fundamentalmente ha sobreactuado
las situaciones que uno ve que se
plasman a la interna y a la externa y ya
lo vemos o lo hemos visto en lo que fue
el bloqueo total al puerto de shanghai
con un solo anuncio de omicron en un
país ellos cierran un puerto totalmente
acá de nuevo tenemos una sobreactuación
muy importante de china hace una visita
que no parecería tan importante y como
entender la advertencia de china de que
no se quedarán quietos con la visita y
de que washington está jugando con fuego
indudablemente los países que tienen
baja institucionalidad y en definitiva
no tienen unas democracias y situaciones
que los pueden de alguna forma darle
mayor garantías y seguridades que tienen
tienden a dar este tipo de anuncios
hoy hoy por hoy la presidenta del
congreso lo que está haciendo es visitar
otra democracia no olvidemos que taiwán
es una democracia real con su forma
republicana y con su parlamento
establecido en la presidenta de taiwán
es una presidenta por voto libre y
general hoy lo que está haciendo pero si
es una visita formal a lo que serían sus
sus países o en este caso democracias
amigas usted previamente dijo que china
básicamente está sobreactuando y que la
visita no tiene mucha importancia si es
así porque le interesa al congreso de
eeuu reiterar el apoyo a taiwán con esta
eventual visita de pelosi y si es
realmente o no necesario el viaje
eeuu ha tenido una política un tanto
extraña para con taiwán de los últimos
años hacia acá ella eeuu reconoce una
única china que es china continental o
sea china pekín dándole a taiwán otro
rango de reconocimiento naturalmente de
comercio totalmente con taiwán y en
especial armas etcétera etcétera y
además tiene un acuerdo una ley por así
decir que se plasma en el congreso de
protección a la no invasión de china
pekín hacia taiwán
en definitiva
es importante
taiwán hoy para eeuu creo que es
importante visitar a cada uno de sus
socios en asia es importante de alguna
forma también que el mundo libre tenga
su propia óptica y su propia forma de
poder compensarse y tener sus gestiones
no siempre hay que ceder a las presiones
de otros sistemas que en definitiva no
están acostumbrados a que se les
contradiga o que haya oposiciones a sus
propias ideas carlos gracias por estar
con nosotros en france 24
gracias a ustedes cambiamos de noticia
irán dice que tiene la capacidad técnica
para producir una bomba atómica pero que
no tiene intención de fabricar la ese
fue el pronunciamiento de mohammad
eslami el jefe de la agencia de la
energía atómica del país persa y así
reiteró lo que ya había dicho cam
alcarràs y asesor principal del líder
supremo iraní está advertencia llega el
mismo día en el que el ministerio de
relaciones exteriores iraní señaló que
existe la posibilidad de reanudar las
conversaciones para intentar revivir el
acuerdo nuclear de 2015 que se fue a
pique luego de que eeuu se retirara y la
nación persa escalará su producción de
uranio enriquecido
el elemento base de las armas nucleares
esto dijo el vocero del ministerio
[Música]
después de intercambiar mensajes la
semana pasada y revisar los textos
propuestos
[Música]
existe la posibilidad de que en un
futuro cercano podamos llegar a una
conclusión sobre el momento para una
nueva ronda de negociaciones nucleares
[Música]
y en irak crecen las tensiones por las
divisiones políticas hay una
contraprotesta liderada por la alianza
pro iraní marco de coordinación intentó
ingresar a la zona verde allí es donde
está el parlamento iraquí y la mayoría
de las embajadas el lugar en bagdad está
tomado desde el sábado por los
manifestantes que respaldan al clérigo
nacionalista múqtada al-sadr a ellos se
oponen a que ya al sudaní aspire a ser
el primer ministro pues cuenta con el
respaldo de irán y también del ex
premier nuri al-maliki el gran rival de
alzar ante los choques las tropas de
seguridad iraquíes reforzaron la zona
verde y así se prolonga la crisis
política del país en el que el
parlamento no ha elegido a un presidente
ni a un primer ministro desde hace casi
diez meses
en el modelo queremos unas elecciones
libres y justas y queremos una enmienda
a la constitución pero lo más importante
es poner fin a la corrupción que
acabamos con la corrupción entonces
ganaremos la corrupción está por todos
lados si tratan de negarlo entonces les
digo revelen los archivos somos los
primeros en pedir que se revelen a todos
el contenido de los archivos que tienen
sobre la corrupción en el gobierno y en
los partidos políticos
la coalición gobernante del presidente
senegalés macky sall se proclamó
vencedora en las elecciones
parlamentarias del país que se
celebraron este domingo la oposición
rechazó el anuncio y también se declaró
ganadora de la jornada electoral los
resultados definitivos se conocerán a
finales de esta semana
al caer la noche en dakar llegaron
informes contradictorios de la coalición
gobernante y de la oposición
los partidarios del alcalde de la
capital que también es líder de la
oposición estallaron con canciones y
bailes e incluso el propio bate de mijas
desfiló por las calles cientos de
personas salieron tras ver los supuestos
resultados en internet personal
magnífico se destaca vi los resultados
en instagram es excelente realmente
excelente estamos muy muy contentos
vamos a estar de fiesta toda la noche
aunque el recuento sigue en marcha y no
se han publicado las cifras oficiales
los partidarios de ambos bandos
reclamaron la victoria eso incluye a la
propia jefa de la coalición presidencial
[Aplausos]
ganamos 30 departamentos de los 46 que
tiene el país
[Aplausos]
esto nos dará sin duda la mayoría en el
parlamento
la oposición remachó estos comentarios y
el alcalde de dakar dijo que la
cohabitación era inevitable los comicios
del domingo eran una prueba clave para
el presidente macky sall después de que
en las elecciones locales de principios
de año la oposición obtuviera triunfos
en varias regiones como ocurre en gran
parte del mundo senegal sufre un aumento
de la inflación y del coste de la vida
algo en lo que se centró en la campaña
la asamblea que vamos a elegir debe
ayudar a la población los diputados
deben hacer todo lo posible para reducir
el coste de la vida y permitir que los
jóvenes se encuentren trabajo para que
senegal pueda desarrollarse las
elecciones parlamentarias deciden de los
165 escaños del parlamento nacional para
los próximos cinco años la oposición
también ha dejado claro que quiere
impedir que mcchrystal se presente como
candidato a un tercer mandato algo que
prohíbe la constitución los resultados
provisionales se esperan máximo para el
viernes
ahora hablemos de la viruela del mono
porque se registraron dos nuevas muertes
consecuencia del brote y por fuera del
continente africano india confirmó este
lunes el fallecimiento de un joven de 22
años en el estado sureño de kerala el
joven acudió a un hospital local el 26
de julio tras presentar fatiga y fiebre
por otra parte se reporta otro deceso en
el continente americano esta vez en perú
donde las autoridades confirmaron el
fallecimiento de un hombre de 45 años
que había abandonado el tratamiento
contra el vih que también padecía así ya
se han reportado cinco decesos por
viruela del mono y por fuera de áfrica
las otras muertes fueron dos en españa y
una en brasil
y terminamos con una celebración nos
vamos a londres donde la selección
femenina de fútbol festeja con sus
seguidores la eurocopa en la que
inglaterra venció a alemania las
futbolistas inglesas fueron a trafalgar
square para exhibir su trofeo
agigantaron sweet caroline de neil
diamond que se ha convertido en el himno
para los equipos de fútbol ingleses
mientras que en la famosa calle de
picadillo y mostraron una pantalla con
la frase felicitaciones leonas
escuchemos lo que dijo la capitana del
equipo lee a williams
en la tierra ha organizado un torneo
increíble y hemos cambiado el juego en
este país con suerte en toda europa y en
todo el mundo pero dijimos que queríamos
que nuestro legado fuera ganar y eso es
lo que está bien en andas hoy día
llegamos al final de las noticias los
invitamos a que nos sigan en todas
nuestras redes sociales en donde
aparecemos como france24 jon al piso s
nosotros nos vemos en minutos para más
actualidad internacional
[Música]